[موسيقى]
مرحبا ثنائيه يحب هالجمهور وهي ثنائيه
مصطفى خاطر ومحمد عبد الرحمن في كشف
مستعجل اللي بدا عرضه على المنصات رمضان
قبل التلفزيون هذه السابقه تحدث اللي
المره الاولى يلعب فيها مصطفى خاطر دور
مريض نفسي وقاتل المحترف وهو دور اللي
يلعبوا للمره الاولى انا بحب الكوميديا
دايما بتبقى كوميديا مواقف
وشخصيات هنا الكوميديا بتبقى كوميديا
حقيقي بعمل شخصيه يوسف يوسف بيروح للدكتور
سهام اللي هو محمد عبد الرحمن توته بيروح
بيقول له هو قاتل وعاوزه يعالجه من الاكل
والتاني بيتملص طبعا من من قاتل محترف
داخل عليه عشان يعالجه من الاكل فبيهدده
وبيقولوا لو ما قتلتنيش لو سوري لو ما
عجبتنيش انا هقتلك
ومن هنا بتبدا رحله رحله البطل
ريحه الابطال يعني انا ومصطفى الحمد لله
بكلام الناس
كميتنا حلوه مع بعض
احنا الاتنين واخدين الموضوع على قلبنا
قوي ان شاء الله عايزين نعمل حاجه حلوه
مركزين جدا استاذ شادي بيسوقنا في الحته
دي ان احنا نبقى مركزين ما حدش يطلع بره
الكراكتر بتاعه لازم تعمله حاجه كويسه
فالصراحه يعني بجد كل اللي حوالينا
بيدعمونا من شركه انتاج واستاذ المخرج
العظيم استاذ شادي الرملي ومؤلف المسلسل
استاذ ايهاب ليه اللي جاب لنا ورق حلو جدا
اليكم ابرز ما غردوا به عن العمل
[موسيقى]
انها حقا عائله سعيده نعم حقا
ده متحول ولا ايه
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات